it is uh Columbus Day longtime listeners
of this show will know that it is a
tradition on Columbus Day for me to
carve out a section of the show to talk
about the holiday and why it deserves to
be celebrated despite what the leftist
crybabies and historical revisionists
might say and I will continue with this
tradition for as long as the holiday and
the manic commemorates remain under
attack which means that I will continue
it indefinitely now if you hear uh
Columbus acknowledged at all today in
the media or by any political or
cultural figure of note it would almost
certainly be a condemnation you know
they will tell us that uh the same thing
they've been telling us for many years
that Columbus was a genocidal Maniac
whose arrival led to the alleged
genocide of so-called Native Americans
or quote unquote indigenous people in
the same breath without a hint of irony
they will also decry what they describe
as overly simplistic portrayals of
Columbus and his voyages hoping you
don't notice how no portrayal of
Columbus is as absurdly and cartoonishly
simplistic as the one you get from these
very same people now as mentioned I have
made the case many times why uh for why
Columbus deserves to be celebrated
deserves to have his federal holiday his
statues his cities named after him and
the case is pretty straightforward
Christopher Columbus was a very great
man and one of the most consequential
figures to ever live on planet
Earth he quite easily had more of an
impact than every single one of his
modern critics combined times a
thousand these are the people that we
give holidays to or used to the people
who shape the world and say whatever
else you want about Columbus he did more
than almost any other single person in
history to shape the world we live in
today now it's often said by idiots who
claim to be in intellectually nuanced
that if Columbus did achieve this
worldshaping feat he did it accidentally
now even if that's true it wouldn't
change his significance or the
significance of what he accomplished but
it's not true he may have been looking
for the East Indies in other words he
was looking for land he knew existed
rather than looking for land he didn't
know existed so could not have been
looking for by definition but there
there was nothing accidental about his V
Voyage you know he didn't trip and fall
and drift across the Atlantic rather he
led a small Fleet of ships over an
unknown ocean without the use of any
modern navigational equipment without
even a map to guide the way and you
would think that this would be a rather
impressive thing to Modern people who
can't manage to drive to the Starbucks
three blocks away without the assistance
of satellite
navigation but that would require modern
people to have humility and perspective
both of which are in short
supply now over the course of his four
voyages Columbus discovered many
Caribbean islands and explored the coast
of Central and South America the full
scope of what he had discovered would
not be fully understood until after he
died but the fact remains that Columbus
brought Western Civilization across a
vast and Uncharted and dangerous sea and
into a previously unexplored and unknown
hemisphere of the globe he forever
changed the world and he changed it in a
way and to a degree matched by very few
other people who have ever lived on the
planet and aside from Jesus Christ
exceeded by perhaps no
one he did this through his courage and
his daring and his Brilliance and his
vision all things worth admiring and all
virtues that Columbus possessed in far
greater quantity than any of his smarmy
Petty non contributing
critics was Columbus a deeply flawed man
could he be brutal and unjust yes
welcome to almost any great man who has
ever
lived sure Columbus captured slaves he
executed both Spaniards and Indians
under his rule he took gold he was by
all accounts a pretty bad Governor this
was a common flaw of explorers of that
era many of them were brilliant on their
ships but incompetent or downright
horrible On Solid Ground uh mellan for
example made it 3/4 of the way around
the world before getting himself killed
in a needless conflict with the tribe in
the Philippines you know there was a
certain type of man who was needed to
navigate a fleet of ships across
uncharted waters and there was a
different kind of man often times who
was needed to manage settlements
unfortunately the latter type had no way
of getting to the settlement except by
hitching a ride with the former and the
former wasn't often willing to seed
control of the land he had just gone
through all that trouble of discovering
a somewhat understandable reluctance I
think now now there's nothing wrong with
acknowledging the flaws of men like
Christopher Columbus nobody is
suggesting that we should honor them as
perfect people or worship them as Gods
the point of the statues and The
Monuments and the holidays Etc is to
remember and celebrate the indispensable
role they played in establishing the
civilization in which we all live now a
civilization that just so happens to be
the freest and most prosperous in the
history of the
world Columbus through his navigational
Brilliance boldness courage vision and
determination is one of the men we have
to thank for that and we should thank
him for
that now some people might claim that
Western Civilization is nothing to be
thankful for at all but I can't help but
notice that those people still choose to
live here enjoying the Comforts and
freedoms given to them by the very men
whose monuments they deface and holidays
they
cancel they claim this is stolen
land yet they remain on it basking in
its
luxuries the fact is that they would
much prefer to live in the colonized
version of this land than the
alternative most Indian tribes were
about 5 to 6,000 years behind the more
advanced civilizations on the other side
of the
ocean so when
those people beginning with Columbus
came to the new world they were going
back in time by about 5 to 6,000
years um if those people on this side of
of the world were left to their own
devices by now they probably still
wouldn't have even invented the wheel
that's how far behind they were and that
is not a world that any supposed
opponent of colonization would want to
live in no matter what they
say which brings us to the day that has
come to replace Columbus Day and now
you'll hear most people in the
mainstream talk about indigenous
people's day Joe Biden recognized
indigenous people's day in a
presidential Proclamation for the first
time two years ago in many corners of
America Society is is it is entirely
supplanted Columbus Day but indigenous
people's day is a total farce and a
disgrace and a joke for several reasons
that I'll explain first it's not a real
holiday it is a political statement it
is a protest it was a thing invented
specifically to overshadow Columbus Day
leftists don't understand why this is a
problem because everything they do is
reactive in this way their whole
cultural agenda is is designed to
supplant destroy dismantle the old
traditions and old values they have no
ideas of their own they have nothing new
or interesting to say they just have a
bunch of things they don't like and want
to destroy for reasons they can barely
articulate people always say happy dog
happy life I know I'm saying that all
the time every day I say that it's my
Mantra in my house well you know if
that's really the case you need to be
giving your dog rough greens
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough grain is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
before started feeding my dog rough
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr
Dennis black is so confident Ruff greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a free jumpstart
trial bag so your dog can try it a free
jump start trial bag that can be at your
door in just a few business days go to
Ru greens.com mat or call 844 ru700
that's rfffg greens.com or call 844
rough 700 today Columbus Day celebrates
one of the greatest historical figures
to ever lived indigenous people's day is
a political tactic meant to undermine
that same historical
figure so if you want a real holiday in
order to celebrate indigenous people
then get your own day okay try for once
to come up with one idea that isn't
designed to Simply Be the opposite of
some someone else's
idea think for yourselves for a change
you damned halfwit
plagiarists second the underlying
premise of the day is false you know
this is supposedly a day to acknowledge
the people whose land was stolen by
European settlers but the whole stolen
land thing is
preposterous you know there there were
maybe as low as one or two million
Indians living on the nor the entire
North American continent by the 15th
century and most there were maybe 15 or
20 million okay a wide range we don't
know exactly how many people were here
but but but either way that's not a lot
of people and the point is that the vast
vast majority of the land was unoccupied
North America and Central and South
America these were mostly Untamed
unexplored uninhabited
wildernesses the smattering of tribes
spread out across 9 million square miles
in North America they didn't own the
whole
thing people these days talk as if the
Europeans had no right to come here in
the first place which is an interesting
assertion from open borders Advocates
but that's obviously absurd on its face
the tide of civilizational expansion and
progress was not going to be held back
forever and the idea that a ragtag
collection of Waring Stone aged tribes
somehow laid Eternal claim to this
entire hemisphere is just
insane it is
crazy the land was destined to be
conquered by more civilized and advanced
people and it was and thank God it
was third the whole concept of
indigenous people is arbitrary if not
totally
nonsensical okay like I think we should
stop we should stop
calling we should stop using indigenous
and native to describe the group of
people that that uh it usually
describes what makes a person indigenous
exactly how long does their lineage have
to be present here like if I can trace
my family back a 100 years is that not
good enough 200 years 300
years the Absurd reality is that if you
are a white person living in the United
States of America and your ancestors
arrived here on the Mayflower 400 years
ago you still somehow do not count as
either native or
indigenous this is not your native land
even after four
centuries okay your family could have
been here for 400 years
building uh this
society and somehow even after all that
time this is not your native land you're
told so where is your native land
exactly if you are not indigenous to
this place the place where you were born
and your parents were born and your
grandparents were born and your
grandparent grandparents grandparents
were
born then where are you
indigenous you know the the answer from
these people the answer is nowhere the
cultural powers that be they want you to
consider yourself ancestrally
homeless you belong nowhere you are a
usurper and an Invader no matter where
you go you have no native home no matter
how long your family has lived
here now nobody applies this standard to
the so-called indigenous people
I always hear they were the people who
originated here what do you mean
originated here what do you think they
you think they climbed out of the ground
you think they grew on trees what do you
mean originated here you
idiots all of the so-called indigenous
people they all descend from people who
came here at some point in the past and
fought over the land and killed each
other brutally for centuries to claim
whatever slice of it they possessed
before before the white settlers
arrived and then those settlers did the
same thing that the so-called indigenous
people did they fought for the land and
they
won they built a life for themselves
through work and toil and hardship and
blood they won get over it they
won and this is our land
now yet we're supposed to live in a
state of Perpetual shame over this
history hell
no I don't play that game this is my
home I am native to this country I
originate here it's where I was born
it's where my children were born I
belong
here I am proud of our history I am
proud of The Men Who Built our
civilization I celebrate those men I
will continue to celebrate them were
they colonizers
sure they were and I celebrate that too
okay I celebrate the fact that they
colonized this land I am glad they did
it because what they did is they forged
into an unknown Wilderness and they
built a life for themselves expanding
western civilization in the process it
was a virtuous
act and through it they earned the right
to call this place home and for all of
their descendants through the ages to do
the
same that is why they get the holidays
they earn
them and it's also why ultimately today
indigenous people's day that ridiculous
fake disgrace of a
holiday is
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there